when dictators lose power
they sometimes fade into relative
obscurity in talk of the devil Italian
journalist Ricardo or it Co turns the
spotlight back on seven of these
infamous leaders for one-on-one
exchanges about their reigns he spoke
about it recently at the Carnegie
Council in New York City for about an
hour
good morning good morning I'm Joann
Myers director of Merrill House programs
and on behalf of the Carnegie Console I
like to welcome our members guests and
c-span book TV and to thank you all for
joining us as we've welcomed Ricardo
awit CEO he'll be discussing his latest
book talk of the devil encounter with
seven dictators did you ever wonder what
happened to the tyrants who terrorized
their country men whose names once
struck fear into the hearts of their
designated enemy's men his names are
synonymous with barbarous brutality
callousness greed and were responsible
for the deaths of thousands where are
they now that their reign of terror are
over how did they disappear into
anonymous retirement and fade so
completely from the world's
consciousness and why were they given
sanctuary and protection enabling them
to live a comfortable existence
essentially going unpunished
for their heinous acts for many years
questions like these haunted our guest
this morning inspired by newspaper
clippings he once kept about two former
African dictators accused of cannibalism
ricardio ratio set out to track down
some of the more notorious dictators of
the 20th century who had fallen from
power in an effort to see if they had
gained any insight into their prior
actions eventually he was able to locate
some of these infamous tyrants deposed
and living in ignominious exile both
pursued by mr. Verret CEO include five
to pose
dictators and wives of two others the
seven written about our idiom in of
Uganda
Colonel Manette sue former ruler of
Ethiopia baby doc Duvalier of Haiti
general Jarl [ __ ] the former polish
head of state john vidal casa the self
proclaimed emperor of the central
african republic under hat sir the widow
of the dictator who presided over
Albania and Mara Milosevic wife of
slobodan milosevic he is the first head
of state to be inducted for war crimes
against humanity and is the only one
behind bars and the only one on trial in
the hague these interviews which are
chronicled in the talk of the dead
create an important excuse me talk of
the devil create an important document
of what Hannah Arendt once described as
banality of evil whether they ruled
under the guise of fascistic nationalism
communism religion or voodoo they all
appear to share certain similarities
called personality torture a secret
police loyal only to the leader and a
systematic looting of whatever wealth
the country had today as so many us are
wondering what happened to Saddam
Hussein this presentation is not only
timely but it is also an educational
study of corrupting power and evil in
exile perhaps one day Saddam too will
resurface in a friendly state ricardio
ratio was born in Italy and has lived in
London where he was a correspondent for
La Repubblica and has also resided in
Atlanta where he was a senior editor at
CNN he has covered the wars in the
Balkans and has filed reports from more
than 80 countries
his first book lost white tribes
journeys among the Forgotten told the
European colonists till the story of the
European colonists who landed in Africa
Asia and the Caribbean to found
permanent outpost of the great Empire
this book was shortlisted for the Thomas
Cook travel book award as a foreign
correspondent he has covered war peace
and all that happens in between he has
recently settled in Kenya for a second
life among the Maasai warriors please
join me in giving a very warm welcome to
our guest this morning ricardio
John
ladies gentlemen thank you very much for
inviting me here today with you I'm
extremely happy to spend a few moments
with you and to be in an institution
that devotes itself to the study of
ethics and International Affairs the
reason is that one of the many questions
I asked myself during my journeys in
search of the post disgraced retired
monsters and tyrants was whether ethics
and international affairs are compatible
and can be consoled just to give you a
more Spanish but why this question
popped up all the time my mind while I
was meeting this formerly famous and now
in famous people is that obviously when
I was in Jeddah in Saudi Arabia meeting
Idi Amin somebody responsible for the
death of three hundred thousand people
in Uganda and a man known for mix of
farce cruelty throughout his career as a
president and and strongman of Uganda I
was wondering why is the Saudi royal
family giving safe harbor to such a
person is Islamic solidarity enough to
justify the fact that this man rather
than sitting in the hague with mr.
Milosevic is exercising at a local gym
in Jeddah without a worry in his head
possibly still involved in some murky
affairs in Africa I discovered that is
still sending
antennas with sensitive material to his
elder son who is the head of a militia
fighting against Ugandan sin that little
tragic corner of Africa where southern
Sudan northern Uganda eastern Congo meet
the same question can be asked of any
other situation situations
why was the self proclaimed emperor of
Central Africa Bokassa Jean Bedell
Bokassa you will remember him because of
the diamonds given to Jesus God this
thing as a as a personal gift
why was he allowed to go to to France
after being the post by the French
obviously why is minge stow the red
Nagus of Ethiopia again responsible
directly or undirected for the deaths of
hundreds of thousands of counter
revolutionaries as they were labeled by
by him by his cronies in in Ethiopia
after the collapse of the gain of the
royal family of the GOP of the imperial
family rather why is he in Zimbabwe
protected by President Robert Mugabe of
Zimbabwe but let's be very very
harnessed in in all this it is not only
developing countries it is not only
dodgy regimes it is not only
undemocratic governments and leaders who
find sometimes that realpolitik has to
prevail over ethics in this country in
Florida there are many former strongmen
from southern half some America and
Central America specially some of them
even considered responsible for the
death of American citizens who live
quite peacefully with the green cards
and you know in a way protected France
decided to give asylum to Jean Bedell
focus on the son of Papa Doc Duvalier
sorry I was sorry I'm confused with
baby doc Duvalier the son of Papa Doc
Duvalier in 1986 when he fled Haiti and
he was in desperate need for again a
safe harbor and many other countries are
ready to give the same sort of asylum a
mirror markavitch dr. Markovic as she
wants to be called the wife of a
slobodan milosevic and the woman
considered the real political brain
behind the career of slobodan milosevic
is now in moscow together with her son
clearly the Russians are very happy to
upset Washington are very upset are very
happy to upset that in how the Western
Europe in giving asylum to somebody who
maybe should be under trial together
with the with the husband well these are
questions that I do not necessarily want
to you know to answer they just came
naturally to me while I was doing my my
research one of the things that people
ask me is why I was interested in in the
post dictators basically I think the
real question is why I was interested in
people who don't matter anymore
who are not relevant whose opinions
ideas even personal situations cannot
change a single inch in the you know
international arena none of these people
can go back to their countries none of
these people have the slightest hope of
returning to power none of them is
leading a serious political movement
basically none of them really deserves
an interview and again I'm not sure that
I have a precise answer but I can tell
you that throughout my my you know small
journalistic career I always felt
attracted more by marginal people in
marginal places rather than mainstream
people in places
because of two elements one very
personal the personal curiosity to know
what happens in those corners of the
world where reporters are not normally
sent and in in this regard my my my
friend and teacher Rishi Kapoor schinsky
I taught me a lot and the second reason
is because I found out eventually
that there is sometimes a lot of truth
or maybe there is even more truth in
marginal stories then you can find in
mainstream stories rather than
interviewing the Italian Prime Minister
I would be interested in interviewing
the former Italian Prime Minister
because I would like to see the human
side of how he changed his life when I
try and look for Idi Amin for Bokassa
for Mengistu for nazmi Raja the widow of
amber ogia for 50 years the absolute
ruler of Albania one of the most
difficult closest and strangest
countries on earth when I was looking
for an interview with dr. Markovic in in
Belgrade
I was not necessarily looking for a
confrontational conversation with them
in a way because I was not I didn't want
to repeat the obvious we all know what
they did we all know that their
reputation is gone forever we all know
what we journalists have been writing
about the IDI amin's the Picasso's of
this world thought for many years what I
really was looking for was their side of
the story and I was hoping to give them
as much rope as possible and I was
hoping to see them using all the
available rope to hang themselves and I
think they did it in a in a fantastic
way in front of Idi Amin this big huge
man dressed in a white robe in in Jeddah
in Saudi Arabia I asked him mr.
president do you have any regret I mean
let's remember that he's the one who
ordered his Minister of Foreign Affairs
to be killed in front of television and
specified that he had to wear a white
shirt because the blood would result
more visible on television those days
black and white television is the one
who named a street in Kampala after out
of Hilter Hitler and he's the one who
was quite happy to state that the only
problem with Hitler was that he lost the
war I suggested and do you have any
regret and he said no only a little bit
of nostalgia and how do you want to be
remembered how do you want to go down in
history books as a great athlete because
he was so fond of boxing and actually he
wanted to participate in the Olympic
Games as represented boxing
representative or for Uganda when when
he was already president these are
bizarre possibly farcical certainly in a
way cruel answers that the fie what kind
of people are these former dictators but
before focusing on them who they are
what they told me where they are now I
would like to say that we should know
remember you should not forget that we
are all a little bit guilty and you know
we are guilty because we have forgotten
about them and in forgetting about them
in a way we have also have forgiven them
The Killing Fields of Asia of Africa of
Latin America
are still there the victims are still
there but the people whom we believed
were behind those killing fields are now
living in peaceful retirement and we are
not concerned we as media are not
concerned I wouldn't be surprised if in
five years time 10 years time Saddam
Hussein his sons his cronies would be
totally forgotten erased by our social
conscience cancelled by more more urgent
emergencies more urgent two stories new
axes of evils new Wars possibly I
wouldn't be surprised if in ten years
time an average college student asked
who was for them saying would look at
you in a rather embossed way I say Who
Saddam who because this is what happens
now if you ask about Bokassa this is
what happens now if you ask about minge
stow me keys to preside over one of the
most brutal regimes in in Africa a place
where you know there's more than one
brutal regime he was the one who forced
the young pioneers of Ethiopia to march
in the streets of Addis Abeba wearing
the red scarves that he is seen in East
Berlin or in Moscow where in the you
know in the Eastern Bloc regime's
parades he's the one who wanted to
transform all the feudal Ethiopia in a
new revolutionary society where the
Ethiopian army would be seen
goose-stepping along the avenues of of
Addis Ababa and basically he's the one
who ordered his execute he ordered his
soldiers to demand for the price of the
bullets to be paid but the relatives or
the victims after the were executed
because the revolution could not afford
those bullets and it was not revolutions
if those people had to be executed for
obviously for the good and for the sake
of the country yes we have forgotten
about them and we also tend to forget
that amazingly these people see
themselves as great idealists they're
I'm sure out of Hitler saw himself as a
great idealist in other words people
they see themselves at people who maybe
committed some excesses maybe made some
marginal mistakes who doesn't make
mistakes but basically we're pursuing a
political agenda an ideological agenda
this was worse those excesses shouldn't
come a surprise in my own country what
somebody called Machiavelli who said
that D the end justifies the means and
many of the stories I I came across are
stories of people who believed that they
were simply just doing that pursuing an
end even more so some of them told me
like minge Stouffer essence told me that
one of the ends he was pursuing was an
end that we in the developed civilized
world had if not imposed had encouraged
him to adopt those were the days when
when the world was divided into blocks
east and west
minge stir was a young officer from
faraway province in in ethiopia he was
not particularly charismatic he was not
particularly intelligent he was
certainly not wealthy his mother was a
servant in the impaired
palace in addis abeba and he you know
just happened to be in the right place
at the right time the leader of a
council of young officers determined to
change as your Pia forever which
happened now he said you know we didn't
know anything about communist capitalism
we were you know Ethiopians from you
know this fantastic ancient civilization
based on Christianity and based on a
feudal system but we we we had had some
contacts with with the West so it came
very natural to me
to knock the American door and say look
you know we have a new regime here I'm
the boss
let's make business together because we
want to be your friends and he said the
Americans said I'm sorry we don't want
to be involved we you know very busy
with the Vietnam we're not interested in
Africa certainly not in the Horn of
Africa why should we bother with you
sorry yeah if we want we can be friends
but no financial help no military help
goodbye he felt it was his duty of
course very ambitious man knock
asthmatic barbarian beaches to establish
a strong international relationship with
somebody somebody else had your
lieutenant it was Moscow so he went to
Moscow and found Brezhnev in the Kremlin
impression if embraced him and said oh
you are wonderful your revolution is
really great and actually I think you
should adopt socialism as your ideology
and I think you should become the
recipient of our help so Ethiopia became
a client state of the Soviet Union in
the Horn of Africa I'm telling this
little story which has many similarities
with many other stories in other parts
of Africa in Asia in Latin America in
everywhere in the 70s in the in the 80s
and 60s because mister tried
to justify himself saying look you know
you guys told me about east and west
communism and socialism for me it was
all the same I had to choose one but you
know basically I could have chosen the
other side did really didn't make any
difference to me as long as I found
somebody ready to support me and one day
this young man called Gorbachev comes
into power and the Kremlin and I start
having bizarre conversations with my
comrades in the Kremlin and they keep
talking about things like perestroika
and glasnost and I'll say what is all
this about
are you changing are you changing
something because if you are changing
you should tell me because I should be
aware and Gorbachev one day said no
comrade be assured nothing is changing
yes we are evolving a little bit we are
in her new times new new situation bus
socialism is going to stay our ideology
we are not moving an inch from that and
reassured that nothing's change in
reality Gorbachev was arming the rebels
the Eritrean rebels were advancing
against against nagisa
ever advancing on the under european
capital but simply because a Gorbachev
agenda was not to have an imperialistic
agenda in that part of the world and he
wanted to get rid of of minge Stowe
funnily enough it was an American plane
sent by the American administration by
the very CIA who transported Mingus -
who evacuated minister to Zimbabwe what
a perfect example of a Soviet American
cooperation both were absolutely
interested in having mr aft of the way
and a new situation and a new regime in
Ethiopia which happened and I must say
that we all should be happy that
happened
mmm minge Stu says we all been betrayed
by by Gorbachev obviously somebody like
general yells s key the man who imposed
martial law in Poland in 1981 during the
two days of solid Arnage the trade union
led by like Lorenza also feels betrayed
if not by kovachev personally with whom
is still great friend but by the
collapse of the old division of the
world the old water and somebody like
dr. Markovic the the woman who became
famous among friends in the early
seventies when she was a professor the
University of Belgrade and the
university obviously was full of
portraits of marshal Tito then president
of peaceful unified marvelous
socialistic Yugoslavia was she will she
all the time she pointed that those
portraits had said to friends and
colleagues UCT tada one day my Slobodan
will be on indoor sport reporters and
that they were thinking she was she was
mad Slobodan Milosevic was a low-key
manager for a state-owned enterprise and
then became yes a prominent banker but
certainly not involved in politics not
interesting polit in politics again not
particularly charismatic dr. Markovic
was the charismatic woman was the
cosmati person of the family and she's
the one who when I met her she had no
she was she had the famous head rule
which is huge and half a meter a law
high and very thick and for that purpose
I think the story is that she bought an
entire hair saloon in in Belgrade and to
have an address always her disposal but
anyway this is not
the main story was pursuing Bastila you
know it was was amazing to see that
everything changed but her hairstyle
doesn't but anyway when I met her she
said things that made me slightly
uncomfortable and I was not good enough
to give her a prompt intelligent answer
she said you Westerners you use double
standards because in Kosovo we were
simply trying to get rid of extremist
Islamic terrorists who were trying to
destabilize our central government using
terror using every possible way so we
decided that it was crucial for the for
the state to crush these insurgents
obviously paid by Osama bin Laden or by
other similar organizations and we did
it and we tried to do it and Anu
interfered because he said that we were
being undemocratic and we were you know
being unreasonable but when you in the
West were finally hit by the same kind
of terrorists then using a double
standard you decided that yes it was
fine to use extreme methods it was fine
to use your military power it was fine
to use emergency legislation so why that
didn't apply to us I don't know if you
have answers to this I'm I have a few
but what am I'm trying to say is that
some of these monsters and maybe is is
what is more terrifying about them are
able to make
to make a point to meet it to make a
political point one even those who are
not particularly political minded take
Duvalier here's someone who told me I
didn't have a choice I was born the son
of Papa Doc what would you have done if
you were born D the son of Papa Doc I
wants to go to university he was not a
brilliant Union student but I'm sure
that the University of port-au-prince
would have been happy to have him but I
wanted to be a normal person at the age
of 13 my father started giving me big
books and biography biographies of state
about statesman about Roman emperors
about the goal about Gandhi about
important people he said you know you
have to read this because one day you
will be in charge they said ok I mean
I'm sure he was not reading those books
just pretending he was reading but at
the age of 19 it was cold in the office
by his father father was surrounded by
the most trusted advisors and said p'tee
um I'm going to die soon don't worry all
is fine what matters is that the
Duvalier wrist revolution goes on so
your sister is a woman she cannot be
charged you are the only man and you're
going to be President actually you're
going to be President for life and he
must have read something because he said
oh but you know the Constitution says
that you cannot be President if you are
under the age of 30 as and in a father
said not to worry we'll change it
constitution tomorrow which Constitution
was changed they made this mistake of
changing Constitution lowering the
minimum age to 20 Papa Doc died before
baby doc was 20 baby doctor was 19 but
that was entirely overlooked obviously
and he became president for life now
Duvalier I mean I'm sure I don't want to
bore you with the bizarre details of his
lifestyle I'm sure you all remember the
plundering of the state money the
disastrous situation RIT was in the
terror caused by the tonton Macoutes he
defines he calls it an Tomiko my social
workers and but again even somebody
totally far away from politics basically
all interested in having a good life
which is not having in a moment because
it's totally penniless but somebody like
Duvalier was able to ask me what I found
again a very embarrassing question which
is are you sure that ayiti is now better
off without me than it was under under
my father on under myself are you sure
can you honestly claim that President
arrested you know is not guilty of some
of the same scenes or made you know some
of the same excesses arbitrary not under
to develop under the post
Duvalier government and yes I prefer not
to give satisfaction of an answer and I
pretend I haven't heard the question but
if answered with honesty it's a very
difficult question I didn't do this book
to draw grain you know moral lessons out
of it I'm the last person who could you
know throw the first the first stone so
to say I really just wanted I'm a
reporter I wanted to write stories
individual personal stories that's all I
wanted and you know part of it
sometimes the journey has been more
interesting that the actual meeting with
these people who don't have much to say
but you know pursuing them trying to
understand whether Lee why they hide
that was part of the fun but
what I I feel comfortable in sharing
with you is that is that the monster of
the wife of the monster is not the only
cause of eels he or she when they are
removed are not necessarily giving space
to a future of opportunity hope wealth
progress freedom in many cases it is
true that when some effort was done by
the international community to remove
these people or when these people were
moved because of internal reasons one
coup d'etat after the other then it is
not necessarily true that those
countries prospered again what is the
lesson from this I don't know but
certainly I think we were having small
conversation before it was Nazis only
the responsibility of Adolf Hitler or
was nothing not only the responsibility
of other faiths let +50 fanatical men
around them what about the millions of
Germans even more so let's not forget
that some of these people have been
freely elected I think there's a very
interesting book just just being
published in the United States by a
famous colleague of mine the
international editor of Newsweek for
exact area adorable in this moment the
the title but I will one of the ideas
inside this important book is that in is
that now we tend to confuse democracy
with freedom and liberty the two things
do not necessarily go together because
we heard at the moment that there is
democracy in in a country are we sure
that the moment there is possibility to
you know freely elect
for instance are we sure that the people
live in this country are not willing to
elect a dictator or to elect a
fundamentalist regime or and in a regime
that later will erase many of the
liberties that we were hoping to have in
that country yes
Duvalier baby doc Duvalier was not
elected in a serious way but Mingus too
was the product of of what was at the
moment a somehow genuine movement of
revolt against the emperor haile
selassie and against a regime in a
feudal Regina was was finished in Poland
in civilized beautiful Poland yes the
were 10 million people in favor of of
lack of events are instantly damaged but
we're another 10 million or more in
favor of the status quo in favor of you
know of the welfare state basically
provided by the by the Moscow supported
the socialist regime in Serbia we heard
that that everything that happened in
Serbia is only because of Milosevic and
and and his wife I added in the case of
Serbia was able to just oppose the story
in the interview with Mirah Markovic
with a similar parallel story and
interview with somebody who was who is
now a prisoner in The Hague
he's one of the I think now there are 90
or more prisoner bein prisoners in in
The Hague his name wouldn't mean
anything to to most people but he was
responsible for committing horrendous
crimes on the ground he was one of those
little men you know your next-door
neighbor's basically who one day turns
out to be a criminal
and it was very interesting to put the
two stories together because me remark
which is saying oh no you know we were
the ideologues we were the leaders were
sitting by great dealing with high-level
diplomacy and politics if something went
wrong is because somebody like Seymour
in first name of this person I interview
because he didn't understand what we
were trying to say he he killed it
tortured it's his problem we never gave
him the order to kill and torture and
Seymour says well I did what I did
because I was bein brainwashed by people
like Meera Markovic I did it because I
was made to believe that it was that the
only alternative was the end of these
Serbian people I did it for my children
and believe it or not that's what he
says it's very it's very difficult to to
draw black and white core conclusions as
I said I'm now a look sounds like I've
been trying to do it all the time but I
really I was only looking for a good
story some of some of these encounters
are good stories also so they appeared
to me and well I'm ready to share
further details and if you have any
questions I'll be very happy to answer
but I think it was more than a good
story you made some very interesting
issues and now I'd like to raise open
the floor to questions and I only ask
that you identify yourself and wait till
the microphone comes Jean I'm Jean Fagan
and I was wondering if you felt that
these people lived with any degree of
fear and whether there were they had
taken precautions with security to
protect themselves the answer is no
simply because they cannot afford it
the people I met are not the dictators
were still wealthy powerful influential
like Ana Imelda Marcos or General
Pinochet of Chile those I pursued are
people who are not able to pay the
electricity bill because I wanted the
contrast between somebody who has been
everything and now is nothing so I'm
sure that they would be delighted to
have some security I'm but you see again
somebody like Duvalier doesn't cannot
afford any security and insecurity any
protection but there are hundreds of
taxi drivers in Paris who are former
tonton Macoutes and who are very very
loyal to to him and his family and you
know some kind of unofficial security
I'm sure comes from from them and
similar situations are in another in the
other you know the other cases
I'm personally a nerd with an
international center for transitional
justice thank you very much it's very
interesting I'm wondering if your
conversations included with these
various individuals conversations around
their thoughts around accountability
possibilities when they were still in
power
I recognize that times have changed and
actually are increasingly changing as we
can see with discussions around
tribunals for Iraq and in various other
places and an international emphasis and
a priority in that but even years back
when some of these individuals were in
power their demands for justice and a
possibility they would be brought to
trial or their or their former
colleagues would have been were those
thoughts present in their mind could you
tell and did they somehow have any sort
of deterrent effect as as we always hope
or was there even a sense that that
prevented them from from leaving power
knowing that they could be held to
account mm I think that the seven
stories PLAs Noriega said the eight
stories that are try to tell stories
that belong to a time where it was still
unconceivable to think of an
international tribunal like The Hague or
like the randon tribunal in Arusha let's
I mean it's a very young idea and still
not accepted by everybody as we know so
I think that this possibility never been
a deterrent in their minds and I'm sure
that they were hoping that if any
extreme situation like being the poser
would ever happen somebody would have
taken care of that because this is what
used to happen until very recently me
but maybe you know still today is we
know with Idi Amin in Saudi Arabia maybe
some somebody else who's giving safe
harbor to to Saddam Hussein
you know they are perfectly aware that
realpolitik dictates these kinda
decisions you don't need to be a
supporter to of Idi Amin to decide that
it's better for not only for him but
it's better for you it's better for the
international community if it
disappears and goes in retirement in in
jeddah that's what I'm trying to say I'm
sure that the American plane sent to to
transport Duvalier to find so to
transport minge co2 to Zimbabwe or the
French government when decided to give
Duvalier asylum etc etc they were doing
it convinced that the word rendering
service to the international community
so no I think that certainly no no idea
of being put on trial ever ever ever was
in their mind I wonder what happens to
the current dictators what they think
now now that a couple of tribunals maybe
also the international tribunal will
become you know more effective that
that's love to ask them
my name is Mary Ann Fitzgerald and I use
fear of reporter in Africa so I've come
across some of these situations if we
take that one step further what I was
going to say before you made your
comment for your an observation that I
wanted you to comment on is that these
dictators foster a culture of abuse and
and either victims or exploiters and
they manage to stay in power long enough
that that becomes the accepted norm so
that even if you remove them you have a
population that is either used to being
abused or used to being the abuser so
that you can't erase that culture very
quickly so it's very easy for the next
person to come in and continue the
exploitation under the name of
capitalism or whatever has ideology has
replaced it so that would justify in
itself apart from the moral issues
having retribution and or accountability
and own courts of justice for these
people I believe it's the only way you
can stop this cycle can you comment on
that I think you are absolutely right
actually in many countries of the media
you know Africa very well and I'm sure
in many African countries people
actually expect a new parent to fill in
the previous position I mean within it
even now in this you know rather
remarkably peaceful and interesting
transition that is taking place in Kenya
even now I think people are slightly
incredulous that do not believe that the
newly elected
freely elected Democratic president is
is going to be totally different from
the previous one I mean there is also a
cynicism I mean being coming from the
most scenic cynical country in the world
Italy I perfectly
you know understand and sympathize with
it you become cynical you say why mr. X
should necessarily be different from mr.
Epsilon yeah so but again that's why
again I agree with you that's why the
idea of a retribution is potentially a
watershed because you are going to be
called responsible even 20 years later
and somebody is there to to pursue you
so yes but this is an entirely new
situation I'm sure will will evolve very
rapidly in the next in the next years is
still in the making why we haven't we I
mean we die I mean somebody would say
why somebody hasn't cashed the Serbian
leaders still at large in in in the
Serbian section of Boston is it really
impossible to capture generalization of
course it is possible why it is not done
isn't he a criminal well no there's no
you know trial yet but yes we know what
he did there is a lot of reluctance to
pursue an agenda that is based on ethics
and international affairs and I'm not
saying this from a moralistic point of
view I understand this reluctance
because if you go along the way of
ethics and international affairs then
you have to be consistent and to be
consistent in this in this area is you
know can prove to be quite difficult
Steve Handelman just to come at that
maybe from a different direction it's
quite obvious why you wanted to talk to
them these guys well what do you think
they wanted to talk to you
what's their what's their interest do
you think were they trying to justify
themselves as they were they do they
miss the limelight but I'm sure you just
didn't go into the local phonebook and
say look up be a purple casa and there
it was I mean it must have taken quite a
quite a job to get to them yeah I got to
them you have to persuade them yeah I
had to persuade them not a single one of
them really wanted to be interviewed
because they reckon and I'm sure their
rights did they have nothing to gain
from talking to me from being in in
another book but yes I suppose you're
right maybe they miss the the limelight
a little bit some of them are getting
old and for some of them it has been if
not the last one of the last
opportunities to give their side of the
story I think many of them really wanted
to try for one last time to clear their
name or at least this is with the excuse
I try use with them say you know this is
your opportunity but yeah I think they
missed it
I hope so in contemporary times I was
wondering my name is Jerry Fuchs I was
intrigued during the Iraq war towards
the end of the war that we were getting
reports about negotiations that were
going on with various people in the in
the military and I wondered what these
negotiations were a Saddam Hussein's son
are these financial matters are these
amnesty matters that is who's
negotiating and under what what are the
criteria here that eventually end up are
you interviewing these people ten years
later from what I've seen I don't know
about Saddam Hussein but what has seen
in previous situations the negotiations
are between three parties the dictator
that is going to be deposed or is
already deposed and looking for
or retirement home the the the power or
the powers who have deposed him well
instead I'm saying obviously United
States in Britain and the third element
is the the government's or the entities
that are ready to give him asylum in
return for some political or financial
return
I mean II diem Idi Amin is in Saudi
Arabia because Saudi Arabia is
interested in keeping some sort of
influence and then in you know in that
part of the world and Sudan certainly
asked Saudi Arabia to to give him safe
harbor as a favor and you know France is
hosting Duvalier in the name of the
Francophonie maybe because Duvalier you
know the value is a faithful mmm no
member of that exclusive club and and
well and in the dr. Markovic and son are
in Moscow because Moscow is gaining
politically from doing something that is
not entirely along the lines of what
Washington and London want I wouldn't be
surprised if Saddam Hussein ends up in
in living in an Islamic country not
because the that's the Islamic country
is necessarily a great supporter of
Saddam Hussein but because for instance
the that Islamic country possibly ruled
by moderate and of moderate you know
elite needs to appease it needs to gain
brownie points with the internal
opposition what's it the bed I mean if
you it's an extreme situation but you
are the Saudi royal family you have lots
of troubles because your internal
position demands more extreme
legislation there's a strong influence
from you know fundamental
from you know business lama clerics with
fundamentalist ideas you give asylum to
somebody like saddam hussein in the name
of islamic solidarity maybe you have
saddam hussein becoming religious peers
when you know religious robes doesn't
cost you much actually in the case of
samson he's bringing a lot of investment
so that's also good and you know you can
say to the Americans that you do it
because I mean either you kill Saddam
Hussein you have to find them a place
what you do it's better to have him
[ __ ] exercise in the gym in Jeddah
then having making troubles in in Iraq
now so you do also a favor to the
Americans so you have nothing to lose
yes you have to lose on the on the
grounds of ethics but
arlynn listen International Institute
for Entrepreneurship development your
point about being elected not at all
guaranteeing democracy is certainly well
taken since we all know
Adolphe Hitler was elected I would like
to ask a couple of questions first of
all did you see these people in any way
as considering themselves to be
political entrepreneurs that they were
trying to create new initiatives and
challenge the status quo and create
something that they felt was better at
least in their own image and related to
that was there any common theme in their
personalities in their characteristics
and their thinking about life in their
rationales of what they had done that
you could that you could tie together I
think I really liked your your
definition of a political entrepreneurs
yes they were and in fact I think that
all of them or many of them yeah maybe
all of them we're self-made men not from
a political background possibly with the
exception of Milosevic wife whose father
father was very important parties and
killed by the Germans but yes you're
absolutely right and you also asked
about traits in common difficult to say
they are very different I mean generally
I was asked he really was very upset
when I told him that he was being put in
same book as Idi Amin and Picassa I said
how can you do that I mean you know I'm
a civilized gentleman of the old school
I did what I did the pursuing an idea
maybe I mean you say I made mistakes but
you know I'm not a Picasso and he's
right obviously he's right
maybe they had the what did the head in
common is the ability to see the reality
around them and I'm not talking only
about the political reality I'm talking
about also the human reality from a very
narrow point of view which is which was
their own narrow point of view the
common trait is that were lacking human
compassion maybe you can argue that that
is not necessarily a characteristic that
a political leader has to have that's
different backgrounds different
continents different stories but they
all lacked
they'd post you know they were not moved
by individual stories of sufferance
which I find quite interesting
wouldn't would some of these deep my
name is Walter burger with some of these
dictatorships known have that as long as
they did if they hadn't gotten the
support of the West and I'm talking
about Latin America and I'm also talking
about some of the African countries
where even today the gobball and and
Togo has dictators that have been there
for 20 years and would not be in
existence if France would not support
them and I think that Pinochet would
never have lasted as wrong if he hadn't
gotten his report in the US and yes I
agree and I think we need to be careful
in not excusing these dictators simply
saying that that's you know it all
happened because of external support but
yes it did happen because of external
support in fact I didn't interview him I
talked to him on the phone exchanged a
couple letters with general Noriega
general Reagan who is why we are
speaking in a prison in Miami had been a
faithful faithful how can I call
informant of the the CIA and the
Pentagon a regular visitor to Washington
and an important element in the American
policy Center mecca for 20 years
and he is somebody who says so
when I was useful I was a hero and now
when I was not used for anymore I'm I'm
a monster maybe I was something in
between you know and please allow me to
go back to Panama but yes it is
absolutely absolutely true on the other
hand you know not only a superpower like
a maker but I'm sure also smaller powers
need to find allies in different corners
of the world and when they find somebody
who's reliable
and who's ready to pursue an agenda
that's compatible with the with with
your own foreign policy interests they
don't necessarily look at your CV they
don't necessarily look at how you know
as your your family they don't
necessarily look at your predisposition
that don't necessarily check if you have
human compassion or not so it's it's
it's an yeah I think you're absolutely
right I also think that is you know it's
difficult even if I'm the first one to
be tempted to be judgmental in this era
cardo I thank you very much for bringing
these stories to our attention and his
book is available thank you very much
Ricardo or its CEO is author